Speaker 1: I want to talk about a story in
which a daughter whose dad recently died of
covid went on CNN and at least partially blamed
Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson for his
role in her dad's covid death, her dad falling
for misinformation, including the misinformation
he consumed from Tucker Carlson.
And they're sort of like three stories here.
One is to what degree, if any, does Tucker
do other media people bear responsibility
for these deaths?
Number two, is there something that feels
a little bit off or exploitative about these
types of interviews with the surviving family
members?
And then number three, something a bunch of
people emailed me about, which is could there
ever be like a legal responsibility for someone
in the media as a result of people that die
thanks to having followed or fallen for that
misinformation?
So to set the stage just briefly, this article
outlines what happened here.
Daughter blames Tucker Carlson's misinformation
for playing a role in Dad's covid death.
The 45 year old father of two had no underlying
health conditions.
A Washington woman whose father died of the
coronavirus said he was hesitant to get vaccinated
because of misinformation he heard in right
wing media and specifically cited Fox News
host Tucker Carlson.
Katie Lane said her father, 45 year old Boeing
designer Patrick Lane, wasn't on the far right
politically.
We'll get to that.
When asked what specifically made her father
refuse the shot, the 20 year old cited Tucker
Carlson.
Katie said her father was waiting for full
FDA approval before getting the shot.
And this is interesting, but by the time that
happened, he was already sick.
One of his last comments was he wished he
had been vaccinated.
And there have been many, many people saying,
I'm just waiting for that full approval, that
full approval has come and gone and many still
not interested in getting vaccinated.
For Patrick Lane, it was too late.
He was, too.
He was already sick.
He couldn't get vaccinated.
Let's listen to some of the interview and
then discuss.
Speaker 2: Why was he so hesitant to get vaccinated?
Katie?
Speaker 3: There there's multiple reasons,
I think one of which was some of the media
that he ingested, he wasn't by any means far
right.
He was right in the middle and he consumed
media from both sides.
And just some of the misinformation on one
of those sides made him hesitant.
So he was going to wait for FDA approval.
But by the time that Pfizer had been approved,
it was already too late.
Speaker 2: Pfizer got the full FDA approval
and your father was already sick.
Evan, talk to me about.
Your final goodbye to your father, did you
have a chance to spend any real time with
him?
Speaker 1: So this is the part that to me
is starting to feel a little bit exploitative.
I've seen a bunch of interviews like this
and and there's a disaster porn aspect to
it.
I'm not feeling fully comfortable with it,
including the desire to figure out what were
the last words.
And you'll see that at a point soon.
John Berman actually asks, were those his
last words?
And I think it's it's the daughter says, well,
those were his last words to my step mom or
something like that.
But there's something that's starting to almost
get, like, salacious about these interviews.
I don't know that I'm loving it.
Speaker 4: Not really.
I was already staying at another house and
he was just coming by to pick something up.
And he didn't even want to get too close because
he was too worried about getting me sick.
So I didn't get to hug him before he left
and then before I knew he was gone.
Speaker 2: You guys are vaccinated now, Evan,
what was the message ultimately that your
father wanted to spread about vaccines?
Speaker 4: He wasn't.
Anti vaccine, he was just hesitant and I know
that, you know, Pfizer has been FDA approved.
I don't think he would have anything wrong
with telling people to get that vaccine.
Speaker 3: Yeah, his final words to my step
mom on a FaceTime call was that he wishes
he wished that he was vaccinated.
Speaker 2: Those were his final words.
Speaker 3: To my step mom, I the last call
that she had with him, he said that he wished
that he was vaccinated.
Speaker 1: So like, what are people with me?
Does this feel somewhat exploitative?
Like I mean, if maybe if the point is just
to convince people to get vaccinated, maybe
this is effective.
I just don't know.
I'm not sure.
Speaker 2: And, Candy, you said from one media
source in particular, he was getting misinformation.
He was getting information that led him to
be hesitant on vaccines.
Who I mean, who was he listening to?
Speaker 3: He he watched some Tucker Carlson
videos on YouTube and some of those videos
involved some misinformation about vaccines,
and I believe that that played a role.
Speaker 2: Evan, what do you want
Speaker 1: people to remember?
So where where to even start?
Right.
I got an email asking more or less about legal
liability, like if you can demonstrate that
this guy wasn't vaccinated because if Tucker
Carlson, could there be legal liability?
No, absolutely not.
I mean, you even if in theory.
So let's see where there's multiple reasons
as to why not.
First of all, how do you you'd have to demonstrate
that no one, were it not only for Tucker Carlson,
this man would have been vaccinated.
The vaccine is not 100 percent effective at
preventing death.
It's very effective at preventing death, but
not 100, 100 percent.
So you could not even prove that had this
particular person been vaccinated, they would
not have died.
But moreover, you know, Fox News has already
argued legally that Tucker Carlson shows entertainment,
that no reasonable person would would interpret
what Tucker says as fact, that it's performative,
that it's entertainment.
And also there are so many instances and so
many media outlets where disinformation is
being spread, whether it's called entertainment
or news.
There's no there's not going to be it would
never succeed to try to hold Tucker.
Tucker Carlson, legally liable for this.
So I guess the questions are given that it's
undeniable that the misinformation does play
a role in people not getting vaccinated.
What could be done?
What should be done from a legal standpoint,
if anything, or is it just a matter of this
is just speech and certainly platforms can
regulate it if they want.
Facebook can say we will police disinformation
content about vaccines.
But that's not a legal issue.
It's not illegal.
It's just Facebook says, well, we're not going
to allow it on our platform, which is their
right to do.
And then lastly, how are people feeling about
these types of segments in general?
The what were the last words and this type
of thing?
Is there an exploitative aspect to it?
Is there an exploitative aspect that's acceptable
if the goal is to convince people to get vaccinated?
Let me know what
you think.